Mannaia, mannaggia che avete cliccato
Eh vo visti che avete cliccato per l'anteprima e per il titolo.
Ho dovuto ho dovuto mettere quella anteprima e quel titolo perché
volevo che arrivasse a tutti quanti questo video, appunto perché se aggiorno Twitter non arriva a tutti quanti
Facebook non ce l'hanno tutti quanti.
E poi sta bene o male morendo. Se se metti i link che non siano di Facebook.
Instagram piuttosto mi ammazzo.
Quindi sono più di due mesi che non faccio video che è successo?!
ragazzi e ragazze
Niente il videdo di compravendita di news, per me è stata la chiusura di una piccola e vero piccola
La stagione dello show. Perché non ho fatto e non sto più facendo video dopo quello? E' molto semplice perché, non
ho più niente da dire. Facciamo una premessa una cosa che non vi ho mai detto
Non voglio essere
altezzoso, non voglio passare per uno che che si vanta perché sembra sempre così quando parlo di qualcosa, ma in realtà sono
con i piedi per terra molto di più di... Ma cosa sto dicendo! Cosa sto dicendo! Vedi a non scrivere i video Dio mio!
Non voglio passare passare per un che si vanta. Però ehh...
Devo dire che da quando ho aperto canale, gli unici video che mi abbiano dato
effettiva soddisfazione personale nel senso che il video possono piacere o non piacere e della base di qualsiasi cosa.
E' i ntrattenimento quindi un tipo di intrattenimento ti piace un tipo di intrattenimento ti fa cagare. E' normale gli unici video che io
Posso far vedere a persone che non conoscono il mio canale,
senza vergognarme, sono ogni singolo video dello mio show! Perché penso sia molto difficile per una web star in generale non solo
chi fa video, ma anche chi fa altre cose sul web. Da strisce di fumetti a musically
a... foto a...
Ask star. Ve gli ricordate le ask star?
Gente che è diventata famosa perché rispondeva a delle domande.
E' molto difficile secondo me per gran parte del materiale che uno crea sul web,
farlo vedere a chi web, non lo comprende appieno.
Proprio la domanda base: "Ah quindi hai 500 mila follower! E cosa fai per avere 500 mila follower?"
-Come?  -aidi  -Ma chi è questo?
lascia perdere gay ormai
ho deciso vado bosco smeraldo!
Allora ciao gentaglia
ehh... rifaccio questo video perché l'avevano già fatto
Però mi sono reso conto che la grafica era troppo alta ehh quindi
Tutti quelli che hanno aperto questo video con il mouse
-Tu sai quello che mi ha fatto vero?
-Non ti sento!!
-Sai quello che t'ho fatto vero?
Peniii!!! Peniii!!! En ci sono dei peni!!
E' difficile! E' difficile! Ma c'è un ma non avendo una base
Su cui fare lo show, nel senso non c'è, non sono io che commento un film per esempio,
quindi la base per fare i video è il film su cui poi io ci costruisco
le battute sopra. No un video dello show parte da zero!
Parte da un'idea, se non c'è l'idea non ci posso costruire niente sopra. E se uno non ha un'idea o semplicemente non
Ha niente da dire
È meglio che non dica  niente e quindi faccio questo video per spiegare a voi che non sono morto non mi
ha rapito l'ISIS
Non ancora e siccome so come funziona internet e quando uno si prende un periodo di fermo ma, non
Dice di prendersi un periodo di fermo la gente o letteralmente non appena morto oppure semplicemente dice bom, non
Ha più voglia di fare video. Il canale è andato
Vissero tutti felici e contenti. Ma è giusto parlare anche di queste cose qui anche perché non mi
Ricordo di averne parlato nel canale perché non è che mi riguardo i miei video io anzi, che imbarazzano no no.
ora parliamo del futuro
Del canale perché tempo fa io dissi una cosa, che ritengo tuttora ancora molto valida
una volta arrivato ai 30 anni
smetterò di essere
Sul "web" tra virgolette la metto un po' generica smetto di fare video te e io questo 4 agosto compio questi benedettissimi
Trent'anni è la mia idea non è cambiata però lo show aperto le porte per tutta un'altra serie di idee che è
che
Qui non posso fare devo cambiare sfondo. L'ho detto,
L'ho detto, è la seconda volta dobbiamo traslocare Simo dobbiamo traslocare di nuovo, mi dispiace dobbiamo farlo dove non
Non, si adesso vi spiego, vi spiego
ho fatto un errore questo, è lo sfondo vero sono
Mezzo metro di sfondo che errore che ho fatto a passare da quello vecchio a quello nuovo, mi sono sbagliato perché ero convinto
Di riuscire a fare invece l'ufficio non. È così grande non è così spazioso per fare una cosa
Del genere ma questa volta sarà o meno
Rincoglionito e quindi prenderò un vero e proprio studio, non
So ancora bene come in realtà ci sto già lavorando ma ci vuole del tempo ovviamente perché, non
È come prima dove dovevo solo allestirlo semplicemente no, qua ho capito che io
Determinate cose con. Lo show che vorrei fare. Da solo non posso farle, non posso proprio con una telecamera due luci e uno sfondo di
Non abbiamo mai sarà 20 x 20 centimetri, no guarda non è neanche
attaccato lo sfondo è tenuto
Su da delle pinze di un vecchio green screen che avevo io, quelle pinze per tenere il filo
20 euro, no non è vero, lo sfondo l'immagine sarà costato un centinaio di euro però
120 euro totali quindi e stando sempre dietro l'idea dei trent'anni come il limite massimo voglio lasciare qualcosa, voglio
Lasciare un'impronta vera su youtube magari voi mi direte ma. L'ha già lasciata
Tu sei uno dei pionieri
Anche dire che mutu 6 uno dei pionieri
Vuol di non è così tanto un complimento perché. I pionieri sono quelle persone che si hanno fatto roba ma basta
E roba passate come tu non. Lo che ti dice guarda che io ho fatto la guerra nonno era cent'anni fa la guerra va
bene basta
Basta anche perché molti mi chiedevano ma come sa come ma questo è un late show e non ci sono quasi ospiti
Si e sapete perché? Non perché sia difficile reperire degli ospiti famosi, voi non avete la minima
Idea della gente che mi abbia chiesto di collaborare al pelo show la minima però io non posso invitare una persona dicendo:
"Sì, vieni nel mio show"
e mostrargli questo
Sta cadendo a pezzi
Voglio farlo bene e voglio farlo più giusto io non voglio che sia uno show dove se tu mi sostituisci con un'altra persona
Funziona nello stesso modo, no deve essere una cosa mia e voglio fare un vero late show
Leggermente più piccolo per youtube molto più fruibile ecco
Servirà un po di tempo e una valanga di soldi ed è per questo che annuncio l'apertura del mio patreon per chi, non
Lo conoscesse patreon è questo sito dove i sogni vanno a morire... No dai
sto scherzando
ale mortacci
Io spero di riuscire a iniziare da settembre non dal primo settembre da metà settembre in poi però spero di riuscire a
Lavorare durante tutto tutta l'estate però non vi voglio promettere niente perché poi va tutto a puttane quindi
Lasciate perdere il periodo potrebbe essere quello e vi aggiornerò nei social con foto dei backstage eccetera eccetera
Io sono carico come uno stronzo per questa cosa a cui io voglio tutto nel mio show?
ballerine cavalli ospiti presidenti degli stati uniti e chi più ne ha più
Ne metta, grazie mille per aver seguito tutto questo video, perdonatemi per l'anteprima per il titolo
leggerissimamente click bate quindi se non ci vediamo
buongiorno buonasera e altre citazioni di film che non ho sbatti si starci dietro dai.
Grazie per l'attenzione.